[Music]
let's go to kathy in austin hey kathy
what you doing
hi how are you
i am outstanding and how about you
better than i deserve oh well played i
like what you did there so what's up how
can i help
hi so um i'm 28 years old and my husband
and i we just got married last year uh
both of us uh we have our college
degrees and we actually both became
debt-free a month before our wedding
very cool you're very proud about that
you should be congratulations what's
your degree in
uh my degree is in finance and his is in
business excellent excellent very cool
so how can i help
yes um so we have our own
uh plan we would love to
travel for a bit we want to do a couple
of things just the two of us so travel
you know buy a house buy a new car
and then eventually we live up to have
children down the line
um how what's been kind of been a speed
bump um with my family in particular
this is
this is really hard i've never really
said this out loud to so many people
um both of us actually were diagnosed
with high functioning autism
aka asperger's and we were both very
young kids
and
my parents have it in their heads that
because of that
i am not capable of being a mother
and i want to know
i would like to know
how boundaries can be set with that and
i also worry
of how my parents it should
reggie and i choose to have
children
how they're going to treat my kids and
how they're going to question my
parenting skills
just the way you said that
hit me right in my guts
and i can't wrap my head around what it
would be like
what it would feel like
not to think but what it would feel like
in my body
if my mom was to say i don't think
you'll be a good mom i don't think
you'll be a good [ __ ]
it's been hurting me for a while yeah
well
that hurt is legit man and i'm sorry
that someone looked you in the eye and
said that it's hard
um so
you say high functioning you guys are
kicking butt doing great tell me tell me
articulate for the listener and for me
what what does that
look like on a day-to-day basis what are
some
things that you feel like
are different from you
for you and your husband than
is for a neurotypical person
well at this point in our adult lives i
think the only thing that i think a
normal person
you know might see is that maybe don't
say normal you're normal you're just
like us
yeah yeah because everybody's got
something right everybody's got a bunch
of somethings
right
well i guess it's
maybe we tend to be on the shy side just
because we want to show a good face when
we meet new people and
just sometimes we have you know quirky
personalities and i think
in my life every other person
has something quirky about them but
otherwise nowadays should anybody
find out whether i tell them or not they
just
didn't know that either one of us was on
the spectrum gotcha and so your mom
is my mom and my dad does she say that
does your mom and dad say that you would
not be a good mom
because of your diagnosis
or because there are things that you
present to the world that concerns them
well
i'm the oldest of four children okay um
all of my siblings are grown up now
and
my dad at one point has said
to me that he has asked each of his kids
you know just as a grown-up when you
start to get into a relationship
or whether
you're in a relationship or not just
look at your life and see
what things could be like whether you
have children or whether you decide to
not have children okay and just to look
at it evenly like same time frame
in which you know at one point before i
met my husband i did consider that
because i didn't think
you know
any man was going to love me for who i
was just because i felt
that my diagnosis was going to hold me
back or if somebody was not going to be
able to handle it and at some point i
actually just stopped telling people
because
they're either going to love you for who
you are or
when they find out they're either going
to
take advantage of it or they're not
going to know what to do and run away so
i just at one point just stop telling
people
that
putting that aside
for you i i realize with parenting i'm
not a parent yet and i understand that
you're not supposed to just see
parenting as rainbows and butterflies
and seeing it through rose-colored
glasses i i realized that
so
is there something is there something
that
are you unable to and i'm gonna ask some
probing questions okay these aren't
accusations these are just facts
are are you unable to
connect with somebody else
no you you are able to connect
absolutely
do you feel your feelings
i do
are you able to interact with somebody
else when they're hurting are you able
to lean into that
yes i can
and same as my husband yeah
so i i think there's a lot of
preconceived notions from people
absolutely
and that's what i'm asking
is this is your mom does she sensing
that stuff i i just can't imagine why
she would say that
and so let me let me get to these let me
get to this because we could spend all
day on this and i don't want to speak
ill of your mom that would be ugly of me
right so
most important be honest
about your connections kids need radical
connection and i want to always go back
to that word that's the most important
thing
just from my conversation with you again
you and i've never hung out i don't know
you and your husband i mean i i
you just sound like a wonderful
extraordinary human being
and
i assure you i've got
if you line up the quirk
the quarko meter i probably got you beat
10x okay
i'm a weird person so they tell me
um
so
if you can provide radical connection
and if you can if you can
demonstrate and model love and you can
make sure people are fed including
yourselves and take care of and all
those things it sounds like you're doing
i don't see an issue at all what i would
suggest is
walking having people walk alongside you
and so
you got that
yes i have my
wonderful wonderful aunt who's also my
godmother she's like a second mother to
me awesome and my grandparents as well
and with that i know that
you know being on the spectrum it might
be a little bit more difficult but
i've been babysitting since i was 13
years old and i took upon myself to do
some part-time babysitting since this
summer
and i've always been cpr and first aid
certified and i just enjoy being around
children that's awesome
and so so
to answer your your boundaries question
this isn't just an autism not autism
thing
um
well let me back up when i said have
someone to walk along the side with you
obviously having a great family member a
good like some family connection some
good friend connections is great i would
love you and your husband to sit down
with a marriage counselor not because
there's anything wrong
but right to
walk alongside as a neutral third party
and i've done this for couples
where you ask the questions what is the
picture of
a saturday morning with an eight month
old what does that look like
right whenever one of us gets overloaded
and we need to disconnect or unplug
what does that look like because you
can't always do that with a baby
right what does
what does taking a step back and
communicating well what needs are right
it's asking all those questions and
begin to map some of those things out
the challenge that
like being around children is awesome
babysitting is awesome
the difference there is kids never go
home
and so there's something about i can
plug in and babysit for a couple of
hours all day and go all in and then i
can go home and just stare off into
space
sure when you've got babies they're just
still sitting there screaming about
something and pooping on everything and
so they don't ever go home
and so being able to map those out with
somebody just a neutral third party i
think would be so valuable and it will
give you and your husband
some
some
clear expectations that y'all can write
down and you can point back to and say
this is who we are is who we said i'm
having one of my saturday mornings where
i need to dis disconnect and unplug for
a bit i need you to step into this gap
or we've got somebody on call we've got
ant on call whatever that looks like for
us
but backing up even further again this
is not an autism question this is just a
parent's boundary question
unfortunately
you can't make your parents accept you
you can't make your parents love your
their grandbaby
i think they will
it's not a matter of loving my child
it's the fact that one they will always
be fearful of my child's safety and
concern 24 7
because they they have that little faith
in us taking care of a child long term
and b
my mom has it in her head that a social
worker has to be assigned to us
specifically oh so here's here's what i
want you to do the research
and that's not the case yeah i want you
to actually reach out to a social worker
you and your husband actually oh you did
okay and then did they walk you through
like they did okay they said regardless
if somebody is on the spectrum adhd
bipolar whatever it is the most they
could honestly do is just go to the
parents house make sure it's
safe make sure the baby's happy and
safe
and anybody who's tried to put a false
claim
that we're about parents we can file a
harassment case against that person yes
so here's what i want you to do
there's somebody who knows you well
and she may be misguided she may have
her own challenges she may be struggling
throwing stuff but there's somebody who
knows you well being your mom somebody
who knows you all being your dad
and they have done an unimaginable thing
in my mind and they've stared at their
child and said you are not qualified or
good enough to be a parent
that's a huge accusation
and yeah my first response is we'll
screw you then
but
i also
always want to
get some data
so i would if i'm you i would go talk to
a professional
i would get my husband and we would go
sit with a marriage counselor and we
would say we want to have kids
and my parents
think that's a terrible idea they want
us out of this deal
and we think we are ready for this
and that counselor can walk you all
through together
and if ultimately in their in y'all's
opinion in the professional's opinion
dude we are going to be great parents
every parent's got their challenges we
know how we're going to work together to
overcome these things we're going to
have the right support around us
that's when you go to your mom and dad
and say
this is happening
you all can choose to opt in and love us
and support us and love this grand baby
or you all can opt out that's y'all's
grown-up decision that y'all can make on
your own i'm not gonna make it for you
we hope you'll join us
but you're not going to
um
second guess everything that we do
you're not going to monday morning
morning quarterback our lives and by the
way this happens for people who aren't
autistic too
over-involved in-laws
and it may be that they are just they
think they are doing the best thing for
this baby and for y'all
ugh what a mess
i can't tell you whether having a child
is a great idea for you to because i
don't know y'all
and there's something bizarre about
either your mom has got some major
issues
or there is a glaring
blind spot in y'all's world that you're
not seeing
and so i want to get you to get a second
opinion with a professional's gonna look
you guys in the eye walk alongside you
for a season
and say man we are ready to rock and
roll it's gonna be great it's gonna be
great or
in my professional opinion i don't think
this is a wonderful idea
and then y'all can have some peace and
then you get to start drawing boundaries
you get to start drawing boundaries and
like your social worker said people are
making false claims against you yeah you
report that nonsense
hopefully your mother and dad will see
the writing on the wall this is gonna
happen
and we're gonna need you we're gonna
want you in the life of our baby in our
lives and we hope you'll walk alongside
us and be our biggest cheerleaders but
if you're gonna throw grenades by
felicia
life's too short
thank you so much for that call kathy
reach out to somebody and man best of
luck to you
i love love love your heart